Thanks Fredo for telling us about the importance of proper dessert selection.
So let's choose our desserts now.
The earliest platform version that our Apple support is Gingerbread.
At the current time, choosing Gingerbread means we can cover over 99%
of the devices active on Google Play Store.
It's also the cutoff for using Google Play Services for things like maps and
location, and the Android support library.
The support library package offers an implementation of UI features that were
added in later releases of Android,
but now can be used on older versions of the platform, so it's really useful.
Notice that we picked the latest version of Gingerbread with API level 10,
because it contains additional bug fixes that API level 9 doesn't have.
Then we can go ahead and click Next.
We're going to choose the template Blank Activity with Fragment.
For background context, an activity serves as a presentation layer for our UI.
And the fragment represents a behavior or portion of the screen.
And now we have an option to modify the names of the files that will be
autogenerated from the wizard.
The name of our activity is MainActivity, and
the layout will come from activity_main, which is an XML file.
In a similar fashion,
the fragments layout will come from fragment_main, which is also an XML file.
I'm going to do a small change for
the name of the menu file to be called main.xml.
Because on an older version of Android Studio that was the default name.
Then we go ahead and hit Finish.
And now you should have a newly created Sunshine app
with the files on the left here.
By default you may see the Android view of the files,
which is a flattened version of the project structure, and
it highlights the key Android source files that you'll need to edit.
In this course, though, we're going to be using the project view because that's
what we had on the older version of Android Studio.
You can choose any view that you prefer, though.
Make sure you wait for the gradle build to finish.
If you have any errors, you can check the guide in instructor notes below.
As a tip, you can check the build.gradle file,
which is located under the app folder.
You want to make sure that the compile sdk version and the target
sdk version are both pointing at the latest stable version of the platform.
In this case, it's 21 for the Android 5.0 Lollipop release.
Once it's done building,
we can add a custom app icon that's more fitting for our weather app.
Right click on the app folder and click New Image Asset.
You can choose from any of the clip art options, or
you can use the one that we provide in the download below.
Then use a placeholder icon we provide in a download below.
And this will show up in the All Apps screen, so
that clicking on this App icon will launch our app.
It will also show up in the Overview space if Sunshine is one of
your most recent tasks.
The other ways you might see this app icon, is in the Action bar of our app.
In certain videos of this course that were filmed earlier,
on KitKat by default the Action bar shows the App icon.
With material design on Lollipop and
later, the app icon doesn't show up a default anymore.
So don't worry if you don't see it.
It's fine, and we're going to be styling Action bar later in lesson five anyways